frank gestern abend liefen die
ermittlungen noch auf hochtouren was
sind jetzt die neuesten erkenntnisse zum
tathergang er die neuesten erkenntnisse
zum tathergang sind dass die polizei
immer noch nicht genau weiß wie die
kinder ums leben gekommen sind wie die
mutter sie getötet hat es werden jetzt
heute feingewebliche untersuchungen
durchgeführt um festzustellen ob die
kinder möglicherweise vergiftet wurden
in solchen fällen hat es leider auch
immer wieder situationen gegeben wo ein
grill in die wohnung gestellt weil die
kinder dann praktisch erstickt sind
das ist aber hier offenbar nicht der
fall deswegen wenn man untersuche die
kinder möglicherweise schlafmittel oder
ähnliches bekommen haben das könnte
vielleicht auch ein grund sein dass
ältere etwas stärkere kind überlebt hat
wenn die mutter ist nicht bewusst
verschont hat weil dort gleich die menge
der schlafmittel nicht gereicht hat hier
am tatort herrscht weiterhin absolut
blankes entsetzen die tiefe trauer und
ja ein schock liegt regelrecht über
diesen wohngebiet hasseldelle hier in
solingen
ich stehe vor haus nummer 155 in dem
diese schreckliche tat passiert ist der
kollege kann vielleicht mal zeigen immer
wieder kommen anwohner stellen kerzen
hinlegen teddybären dorthin und der
schock sitzt ganz ganz tief bei den
menschen die ihr leben
keiner kann es verstehen viele sagen
auch warum haben wir denn nichts gemerkt
hätte man der frau nicht vielleicht
helfen können und diese frage ist völlig
berechtigt denn mittlerweile ist klar es
hat hier einen polizeieinsatz gegeben
schon ende april diesen jahres und zwar
war es dort aber so dass offenbar der
vater der kinder der ehemann der frau
ist offenbar der vater jedenfalls der
jüngeren kinder offenbar einen
suizidversuch unternehmen wollten in dem
mutter dann verhindert hat und es kam
zum polizeieinsatz und die mutter wollte
aber keine keinen strafantrag stellen
der ehemann auch nicht die polizei es
dann wieder abgezogen mit hilfe
angeboten
aber diese hilfe angeboten wurden
offenbar nicht angenommen warum jetzt
die mutter am ende so verzweifelt war
und diese schreckliche tat begangen hat
kann man momentan noch nicht sagen und
muss jetzt auch noch die obduktion
erwarten die mutter selber ist ja schwer
verletzt sie soll danach auch befragt
wird neben mir steht jetzt stefan warnt
er ist pressesprecher der polizei
verwarnt
wie gehen die beamten mit dieser
schrecklich belastende situation um wie
wird ihnen geholfen ja das natürlich
eine sehr belastende situation für meine
kollegen zunächst war die kollegen vom
streifendienst hier die waren im
schnellsten eben vor ort und haben die
kinder dann auch gefunden
das war schon eine sehr starke belastung
ich habe hier kollegen gesehen die
wirklich sehr betroffenen aus dem
gebäude gekommen sind
das gilt nicht nur für uns das gilt
natürlich auch für die kollegen der
feuerwehr die die situation sehr
mitgenommen hat das muss man ganz klar
sagen
im weiteren verlauf später bei den
ermittlungen hat das kommissariat das
fachkommissariat dass ich mit auch
tötungsdelikte neben beschäftigt hier
vor ort gewesen und auch für die
kollegen die da schon recht hart
gesotten sind oder einiges gesehen haben
ist das eine sehr starke belastung ich
habe heute morgen mit dem geschäft der
kollegen dieses kommissariats gesprochen
die haben mir zugesagt oder zugesichert
ich weiß aber auch dass sie aufeinander
gut aufpassen wenn sie merken dass ein
anderer kollegen nicht gut geht dann
sprechen sie dann an es gibt
betreuungsangebote die in anspruch
genommen werden können ist aber ganz
klar so dass jeder mit so einer
situation anders umgeht und diese
situation für sich einschätzt da geht
jeder unterschiedlich mit um
vielen dank herr feiern der mann sieht
auch die beamten die natürlich jeden tag
mit schrecklichen dingen zu tun haben
für die ist die situation extrem
belastenden in einer wohnung plötzlich
fünf tote kinder liegen
ich gebe jetzt weiter zu meinen kollegen
nicht in engelberg der steht an der
stelle in düsseldorf wo gestern die
mutter ihr leben beenden wollte nach
dieser verzweiflungstat man muss noch
wissen sie hatte ihren ältesten sohn bei
sich gehabt hat sich dann bei ihrer
mutter spricht der ober des kindes
gemeldet hat gesagt was passiert ist und
dass sie jetzt den jungen zum glück zu
ihr schicken wird und hat er versucht
sich selbst im bahnhof in düsseldorf zu
töten